uh 7-7 prayer and health ministry says put
zechariah chapter 6 verse 13 in the chat
let me quickly in the youtube chat he's been
the father in the center perhaps that is it let
me quickly flip daler please continue to guide
us in jesus name amen the bible reads even he
shall build the temple of the lord and he shall
bear the glory and shall sit and rule upon his
throne and he shall be a priest upon his throne
and the council of peace shall be between them
amen that's a hint about the arrangement
between the father and the son
from way back from way back regarding what
to do with the fallen world yes but it calls
for a lot of study to see exactly how it
says that amen amen any other question
no i believe that is it okay oh sorry i'm so
sorry okay okay inherently sister cassandra james
do you still have your hand up to
ask a question sister cassandra
okay she says no she says no let me see yes we
talk about the second coming of the resurrection
but we all with the resurrection we should keep in
mind what peter tells us in second peter chapter 3
verse 11 seeing them that all these things shall
be dissolved what manner of persons ought to be
in all holy conversation and godliness looking for
and hasting under the coming of the day of god in
other words peter saying look you know there'll be
a resurrection you know there's a second coming if
you know that how should that affect your present
life it's one thing to discuss the resurrection
who will come up when where what all that's
fine but you can do that in a disconnected way
and it has no effect on your personal life
peter says look if you know this event is
coming shouldn't that affect your day-to-day
life the way you live the priorities what you
spend your time doing and i think we ought to
take that that thought if there's a resurrection
is my life moving in the direction of
participating in the first resurrection which
is the resurrection of the just as i examined
my life for the past six months which direction
am i moving up or down so we need as we discuss
the resurrection now we come to the conclusion
am i ordering my life in harmony with
the imminent return of jesus christ
am i living in such a way that i realized there
is something called the resurrection and whether i
participate in the first or the second is entirely
up to the choices i make and so let us not just
make this an academic exercise make a personal
choice is my present lifestyle jeopardizing my
chances of getting into the first resurrection of
the second perhaps i did not say the right way but
i think you understand what i'm saying we must
take a personal view because someone listening
to me can die tonight god forbid personal
response to this question and answer session
does someone listening need to make a decision to
be re-baptized does someone listening need to make
a decision to stop working on the sabbath there's
someone listening need to make a decision to start
returning the tie does someone listening to me
need to make a decision to break up that romantic
relationship that has disgraced god what decision
do you have to make having heard what you heard
about the resurrection that's coming and i think
that needs to be said that needs to be considered
what is my personal response to this thing called
the resurrection and the return of christ amen
amen thank you so much aldiskeet for that call to
introspection thank you so much and i think to me
needs to be re-baptized i know that i don't know
who but someone listening to me needs to call the
pastor and say pastor i be convicted i need to be
re-baptized and start again with god all over this
time by his grace get it right someone listening
to me or someone's need to make that decision
you